el año cambió pero la atención en la
Península de Corea promete continuar o
incluso intensificarse en el primer día
de 2023 El Líder norcoreano Kim jong-un
cerró la sesión del comité central del
partido de los trabajadores y dejó un
pedido que eleva el temor en la región
el desarrollo de nuevos misiles
balísticos intercontinentales y del
Arsenal nuclear de Corea del Norte
es una situación en la que Corea del Sur
se ha convertido indudablemente en un
enemigo evidente la producción es más de
armas nucleares tácticas es importante y
necesaria y por ello existe la necesidad
de aumentar en proporción exponencial el
número de ojivas nucleares
las declaraciones de Kim Susan después
de que probó un lanzacohetes en la noche
de año nuevo y no pasaron desapercibidas
en los países de la zona el presidente
de Corea del Sur y un superior instó a
los jefes militares a responder con
determinación mientras que desde Japón
elevaron un reclamo diplomático contra
el régimen norcoreano
la serie de provocaciones de Corea del
Norte amenaza la paz y la seguridad de
Japón la región y la comunidad
internacional y no debe tolerarse viola
las resoluciones pertinentes del Consejo
de Seguridad de las Naciones Unidas
en 2022 Corea del Norte tuvo un registro
sin precedentes en los lanzamientos de
misiles el régimen de crime redondea una
cifra que rondó el centenar en noviembre
lanzó por primera vez desde 2017 un
misil balístico intercontinental dicho
cohete tenía suficiente Rango como para
alcanzar territorio estadounidense el
espíritu beligerante que Corea del Norte
mostró en 2022 ha elevado las
especulaciones sobre un posible nuevo
test de armas nucleares que de
concretarse sería la séptima prueba de
este tipo de armamento